طائره انتحاريه مسيره استخدمها الجيش
الاسرائيلي في اقتحامه لمخيم جنين وتحديدا
في حي الحواجين وضد اهداف المدنيه كما جاء
في بيان لكتيبه جنين محللون يرون ان
الاقتحامات المتكرره للمخيم تكشف عن
نقطتين الاولى هي عدم تحقيقها لاهدافها
المعلنه بالقضاء على المقاومه او الحد من
فعاليتها على الرغم من عدم تكافؤ بين سلاح
الطرفين اضف الى ذلك ان اللجوء جيش
الاحتلال الى استخدام طائره انتحاريه يظهر
ان جنوده يتجنبون المواجهه المباشره مع
المقاومين الجيش غير مستعد للمواجهه كان
هذا تصريحا متكررا لضابط الكليات العسكريه
السابق بالجيش الاسرائيلي الجنرال
المتقاعد يضحك بريك ابرزها في تقرير حساس
له قبل سنوات تصل الى المجلس الوزري
المصغر اما الامر الثاني فهو ان هذه
الاقتحمات لها هدف بعيد المدى اذ تعد جزءا
من الميدانيه يهدف الى تفكيك المقاومه في
جنين ومن ثم بدء استيطان شمال الضفه
الغربيه ولاسيما المستوطنات التي اخليت
ضمن قانون فك الارتباط عام 2005 وعلى
راسها مستوطنه حامش هذا الهدف يقع ضمن خطه
الحسم التي يقودها وزير الماليه اليمني
المتطرف بالتالي سبوتريتش الهدف
الاسرائيلي هو ان لا تنعم جنين بالهدوء
يبدا الامر بتسلل قوات المستغربين الى
المخيم تاره بسياره خضروات واخرى بسياره
نقل مدنيه لكن سرعان ما يكشف امرهم وتنطلق
صافرات الانذار في المخيم تنبه المقاومين
يعقوب ذلك اقتحام معلن لقوات الاحتلال
بوحدات النخبه اليوم اقتحمت قوات الاحتلال
المخيم الذي لا تتجاوز مساحته الكيلومتر
مربع باربعين اليه من ثلاث محاور مختلفه
وتمكنت من اعتقال مقاومين من كاتمه العياش
التابعه لكتائب القسام والتي اعلنت
مسؤوليتها اكثر من مره عن اطلاق مكروفات
صاروخيه على المستوطنات القريبه من جنين
داخل الخط الاخضر فهل تحد اسرائيل بذلك من
فعاليه المقاومه